we were dinner and and you said
something to me that was a little
surprising you talked about as a kid as
a kid that you were a huge fan of Frank
Sinatra and I thought that's that's
interesting to me that you would
appreciate Sinatra at such a young age
you were like 10 11 I was 10 10 when I
got interested in Sinatra and when I was
11 for my 11th birthday I went to see
Frank Sinatra live song yes and it was
amazing he came out and he was old yeah
because it was 1993 yep and he was born
you know 93 years before that yeah but
he came out and it was still Frank you
know I'm an 11 year old I said that's
still Frank he still got it and Frank
Sinatra jr. was the conductor you're all
Franken like Frank Sinatra Frank who am
I in like 94 I think I think I may be
sawn the next year and yes his his son
Frank Sinatra jr. conducted his
orchestra conducted the orchestra and
and we're not just doing this you that's
all he did he would like that and he
also cleaned his windshield yeah
we have lots of them but at one point
during the concert and when I say
concert I mean the 40 minutes that he's
saying Frank Sinatra man I gave my son
Frank jr. a job as the conductor of my
Orchestra we all applaud he goes yeah I
gave him a job so he wouldn't sit around
the house smoking dope Sinatra and yes
it was weird and I don't I I think I
found his greatest hits album in a pile
of records and started listening to it
and I was that was an off-putting
strange child
say you're I carried a briefcase that
same year of school you were a little
bowler hat no but I'm not kidding I
carried a breed you really carried I
carried a briefcase to school oh yeah
you were beaten horribly I hope I went
was I was in a sheltered enough
environment where it was okay
I would put my briefcase up on my desk
and and then open it and take out my
homework and it was it's very odd yeah
yeah it all worked out and I would put
shaving cream on my face like a man
would to shave but then I would just
wipe it off do have any idea now why you
did those things you look back at that
time of your life and just as now I
wanted to be a man in 1950